si se debe en gran parte a la nueva ola
de constitucionalismo que nosotros
tenemos en américa latina a partir de
los años 1990 incluso con la firma de
cartas democráticas en los periodos post
dictadura pero yo creo que como américa
latina no debemos confiarnos tanto
porque una nueva ola o nueva corriente
de populismo penal cada vez se hace cada
vez nosotros vemos más discursos a favor
de la pena de muerte aunque tal como
usted le ha dicho no se encuentra
implementado debido al enorme aumento de
la criminalidad común en los países de
américa latina si bien es cierto q
vaivenes todavía mantienen la pena de
muerte no se trata de un sistema penal
un sistema jurídico que deba
considerarse como un ejemplo para los
demás países en la región por lo general
se toma siempre como ejemplo los eeuu
sin embargo aún este país ha demostrado
que se trata de un sistema penal
imperfecto cuantas gratificaciones de
inocencia a través de juicios de
revisión no conocemos nosotros en eeuu y
lo único que le queda hacer al gobierno
es una compensación económica manera de
reparación y nada más lo que demuestra
que la pena de muerte en todo el sentido
de la palabra
tiene efectos irreversibles y usted
habla que gracias a una ola de
constitucionalismo esta pena se ha
disminuido en varios países pero en las
naciones del caribe la mayoría de ellas
todavía mantienen la pena de muerte en
sus constituciones a qué se debe esto
esto se debe a que
el sistema de justicia en algunos países
de américa de américa latina y
centroamérica en especial
todavía mantienen una fuerte base del
como un blog y también del derecho
europeo no
tengamos nosotros que si bien existe
francia se mantiene a la vanguardia en
este momento de la abolición de la pena
de muerte en algún momento también se
convirtieron en la nación pionera sobre
esta clase de castigo y es interesante
lo que propone francia porque el debate
siempre ha sido aún abierto a través de
distintas escuelas recordemos por
ejemplo que la escuela de la
criminología francesa se opuso el
criminal a la escuela criminológica de
numerosos que por supuesto veía el
delincuente como un enemigo nato ahora
yo sí considero que la falta de un
aparato democrático fuerte y sobre todo
de una propaganda legislativa correcta
incide mucho en que este populismo penal
siga siendo una corriente fuerte en
centroamérica especialmente en cuba
sí señor astudillo brevemente porque
eeuu continúa implementando esta pena
lo que pasa es que el sistema penal
norteamericano todavía maneja una idea
de prevención general que como nosotros
sabemos no tiene ningún efecto disuasor
y es bastante contradictorio el caso del
gobierno norteamericano porque
precisamente en los países o mejor dicho
en los estados internos donde más
ejecuciones por pena de muerte hay es
donde más delitos execrables se cometen
como por ejemplo las matanzas escolares
nosotros conocemos varios ejemplos
incluso en la contemporaneidad de los
alguien presidentes de esta clase de
ejecuciones que han dado y sin embargo
queda demostrado que es que esta clase
de sanciones que dicho sea de paso no
tiene ningún efecto utilitarista pues
no logra de sufrir la delincuencia